kareemi and paul are obviously missing
from the tell-all
what can you tell us about why they
couldn't well obviously
the situation between paul and carini is
a very complicated
and sensitive one so when we were
about to do the tell-all their situation
was
very fresh and so we wanted to give them
the space
to really work through that that's
really good to know
i want to move on to larissa because
she's alleging that she was let go by
tlc
just one day before she was arrested by
ice
i know that's still up in the air the
truth whether it's the truth or not
but could you sense that there was a
larger issue going on with her
during the taping of nutella or was this
just
surprising uh no no i did not
know about anything that she may have
been doing
she is going to be a part of the
tell-all so
when you tune into parts two and three
you will see larissa so any rumors that
she's been cut
out of the tell-all are not true at all
and um you know lauris is one who's been
through you know a lot has gone on
in her life so uh so hopefully and i'm
not usually i'm not
a part of any you know any discussions
between her
and the network at all so i don't
i don't know but i do know that she will
be on parts two and three